do you enjoy these am I just lecturing
to you do you would you rather just be
on the beach or something but like I
just well no we could do this on the
beach that you wanted to do that don't
get me wrong I'm not gonna say let's not
go to the beach and do the explainer
okay we prize each other one day we will
do an explainer on the book
all right Beach explainers I'm all about
that we're just chilling and I'll
comment on the waves or tides or
whatever and other stuff right
a lot of good stuff at the beach we
could just talk about some beaches good
Beach is good but that's not what this
one is about okay this one is about just
something that I think people don't
think about much or when they do I don't
think they have as full of thought as
they can so let's go back when I was a
kid and when I was a kid by the way I've
been interested in the universe since I
was 9 so I've been wondering about what
people say about it even in off-the-cuff
so one of the things they said what made
you interested in the universe at 9 now
that we're talking about this I didn't
know now oh listen to my local
planetarium my parents took me and my
brother and sister and I grew up in the
city where you can't see the night sky
right no one in the city has a
relationship with the night sky if you
look up you don't with the night but not
right well no if the nice guy weren't
weren't as dark as it is like on a
moonlit night crime goes down all I'm
saying why do you know so much about
then that's when you do your crime
because that's what happy came
interested you know we didn't do a
background check on you before we hired
you so so anyway most sight lines you
know hit a building and we have to like
look really steep up and even then you
know especially when I grew up there was
air pollution much worse than
and now light pollution worse than now
and so you just don't think about the
night sky and plus even when it's dark
out the city lights up right so you're
not thinking day night but here's what
people said they said days get longer in
the summer right I heard oh yeah people
still say that wait so then I said to
myself well how long is a day
well days 24 hours so I looked at my
watch
and I said okay 24 hours goes by and now
it's tomorrow it's summertime and
somehow it wasn't a 25 hour day all
right so as a young child I couldn't
parse what anybody meant when they said
the days get longer because I was
treating the word day as a literal
24-hour day okay little did I know of
course they're referring to daylight
mm-hmm daylight okay light right so do
you know that I mean I didn't I mean I
had to figure that out
I'm sorry but you would know that's
because you're thinking like a scientist
even at nine years old because that that
is a literal thinking what is the
literal thinking I was not thinking
figuratively or not thinking favorite
Italy you know because most people think
of the day a contingent upon when you
can get work done and from an agrarian
standpoint that's daylight that's the
day okay right get getting all
historical on me yeah but but my brain
was was so not wired that way at the
time and so right I could have probably
was a given enough time figured it out
you know the day oh so the days over
right so he's not saying it's midnight
right that's always written about
midnight they're they like Cohn anyone
know home okay so wait were they working
all night I think they were working
night and I don't know
okay I don't know when but I mean I
don't know when you get bananas I mean
maybe that's a nighttime job man
they begin to may be getting bananas is
a nighttime think bananas hi Jordan the
day I don't know bananas during the day
so so here it is
so we've said things get longer in the
summer and summer
okay so order in the winter okay so now
that I knew what everybody was talking
about they're talking about the hours of
daylight okay right I get that
hours of daylight okay so what's the
first day of summer
I do 20 something I've got June 20th
June 20 it can vary it compares the
number of days does not cut evenly into
a year right so we have to fake it and
we say our year is over even before
we've completed a full trip around the
Sun right okay
and so but when we've backed up by a day
then we throw in an extra day to line
things up again and that's the one that
happened that happened this year it has
run for years
yeah I'm 2020 truck I'm glad you can
still divide by four that's good all the
numbers in 2020 or everything by four
yeah so so here is my issue okay you
ready
are you seated I'm I am are you listen I
am and let's let's stick with the lingo
okay okay truck what is the longest day
of the year
uh June 27 the first day of summer right
right
longest day of the year everybody knows
this well yes okay Chuck if the first
day of summer is the longest day of the
year right then every day in summer has
to be getting shorter oh my god okay
what is the shortest day of the year
it's the winter of December 20 something
September 21st to winter solstice right
if that's the shortest day of the year
then every day after that is longer and
so let's get longer in the winter and
shorter in the summer well did you go
people
once again he has ruined something that
you all thought were true you all
thought that summer was the time when
the day is that longer not so and by the
way what you just said is is so simple
it is almost elegant I mean it is so
simple did this require a grant from the
National Science Foundation to
demonstrate the same people who say days
get longer in the summer are to tell you
that the longest day of the year is the
first day of summer these are two
logically inconsistent sentences they
certainly are that you know and I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you the truth I've
never even considered it because you
know what summer is just so much fun
that you don't want to think of the
day's getting shorter that's right well
while we're there let me just just go in
for the kill here
okay I'm not violent let me go in for
the for the exclamation but since you
don't want to kill anybody let me let me
ask LeMay should point this right okay I
always thought it was odd that daylight
saving time right which takes an hour of
sunlight from the morning to put it at
the end of the day it's giving you an
extra hour of daylight when you least
need it okay in New York City
in June the Sun sets at eight freakin
thirty okay and Twilight is long it goes
another hour however that's right you
know you don't need do you need when do
you need the daylight saving hour
yeah you kind of would want it at the
end of the day what excuse me what time
of year do you need extra sunlight at
the end I want it in the wintertime
thank you yeah Wednesday's err yeah sure
thank you yeah well so so to me the
whole concept of daylight saving time
was backwards and it is growing up I was
trying to come to terms with the world
that I was absorbed Bing as I was coming
of age as a as a child scientist baby
farmers start their day much earlier
than everybody so maybe it's maybe it
was to give them the extra hour so that
well let me excuse me excuse me
well excuse me yeah does the farmer
really care what time it is
no which when does the sunrise and
sunset and what are the crops do it I I
heard someone I heard someone say I
don't like I don't like the same time
because the the crops need that extra
hour in the morning I heard somebody say
that and I said don't check your pocket
I'm like what time you say it is when
the Sun rises or say yes that's funny
it's not like you can walk out to the
field and the corn I'm gonna be like yo
man you lay told us what time it was
corn stalk of corn it's just I got to
throw this in here I didn't realize this
until like I was a grown-up do you know
how many ears of corn grow on a single
corn stalk I thought it was one one is
that one that is crazy
that's crazy yeah that's insane that's
insane
maybe that's why all of Iowa is a
cornfield because you ant them this
close to each other okay I'm thinking
only getting one corn out of all of that
field Oh every time I eat a corn stalk
I'm saying an entire plant gave its life
for me to chow down on this one knock on
the corn cob right
and I felt bad when I learned that
there's a city kid learning about
country stuff late yeah well guess what
I to me that makes corn that much more
delicious thank you occasionally you can
get more but I think it's rare it's
again you basically it's a one corn
stalk thing but anyhow so so there you
have it it's I just oh and by the way
there's a big difference between the
duration of the day in the summer and in
the winter so in New York City we're at
40 degrees north latitude this would be
true also for 40 degrees south and it's
not very different as you go up or down
a few degrees
Los Angeles is 30 degrees north Santiago
Chile is 30 degrees south you know most
of civilization has found itself into
these bands and north and south of the
Equator so we can get 16 hours of
daylight
in the summertime and the inverse of
that we get about 8 hours or less of
daylight in the winter when I say
inverse it's 16 hours a day 8 hours a
night 16 hours a night 8 hours a day so
it's all sort of symmetric that way then
I got another one for you ok if we have
summer going into winter from June to
December right and the southern
hemisphere is opposite so
we have our longest days they have their
shortest days all right there's the two
days of the year where we all meet
because we're crossing with two ships
crossing in the night okay right if we
have longer days than you do and later
on you have longer days than we do at
some point everything equals out right
and you take a get just guess when that
is I'm gonna say the Solstice no no no
so there's two days when everything
equals out that's why it's going good
enough Knox means night so equate so so
on the equinoxes the daylight equals the
night night equinox
everybody is 12 hours a day 12 hours a
night but that's in both places because
we're crossing right that's it okay
all right they're going from winter to
summer we're going from summer to winter
and there's a point where everybody has
to cross and that's window the whole
world has 12 hours of sunlight in 12
hours the daylight oh I love that that's
that's that's that's pretty cool yeah
yeah so I love me the earth earth is a
good good thing so Chuck okay so there
you have it and again I didn't mean to
spoil your understanding of the known
universe no it's not about that
it's you are upset halfway it is you
because you're supposed to enjoy the
longer lazy days of summer and now we
have to enjoy the frantic shorter days
of summer because they are each day is
less and less of the many times a year
instead you will cherish those few extra
moments of light you had today relative
to tomorrow hmm
know me very well see that's not
happiness I'm - damn I'm - I'm -
anxiety-ridden for that it's not how you
roll no it's just no I get it though
this it's it's it's certainly not as
much fun to think about having longer
days you know what I mean like
winter it depends if you're a person who
likes winter then this this is it well I
got I got one for you
okay here let me resolve this for you
okay
alright so that you you will sleep well
at night all right
I think about it if the first day of
summer is the longest day of the year
and summer is you know so wouldn't it
have made more sense to have called that
day the middle of the summer yes so that
the longest day you get the days get
longer going up to the longest day of
the summer and then they get shorter but
that becomes the midpoint of the season
right that's true well thank you would
you feel better about that you know what
I am I do already do feel better because
oh okay it's because now it's not all
downhill that's it so now it's not all
downhill that has already been done
how so in most of the world what we in
America call the first day of summer
let's take England for example you know
they call it a cold the first day of
summer now they call it midsummer ah
gotcha and this is where Shakespeare
gets to name a nice Night's Dream
Midsummer Night's Dream what day of the
year does that take place on June 21st
you go midsummer I've got you I like
that will you sleep well at night
I will now and henceforth will you take
these summer days and nights I spell
indeed
and together we exhumed
all right that's cool mid 7 I'm good are
you good and it is I your science bard
right bidding ye and B and all now
to keep looking
[Music]